[muzyka]
Wsiedliśmy do samochodu i przejechaliśmy przez góry i równiny
na to i
w kierunku faktycznie
jechaliśmy
Jechał samochód okupacyjny i stał czołg
i dotarliśmy do punktu kontrolnego i tam przeżyliśmy
prawdziwe przesłuchanie
to jest właśnie Boży post, który my z Mariupola i
Mogę powiedzieć, że osobiście tego doświadczyłem
rzeczywiście takie upokorzenia z ich strony
bo kiedy z tobą jest łatwo
bardzo tak mówią
skoro tak mówisz Cóż, to słowo przeraża mnie jak cholera
Nie wiem tylko, czy jesteś poniżany
jakoś
[muzyka]
od pierwszego dnia to zrozumiałem
odbywają się tak ważne historycznie wydarzenia
wydarzenia, których po prostu nie mogę
Nie wiem jak tego nie napisać
Co więcej, nawiasem mówiąc, w tych warunkach, w których
po prostu pisaliśmy to dla mnie
był najbardziej pokrewny i najprostszy
bo to tylko długopis i papier
24 lutego
2022 rok temu nie było drogi, oświetliliśmy ją
cały świat jest z nami
następnie mam małą listę, którą I
Chciałem odwiedzić, gdy wygrał hashtag
na razie chciałem go gdzieś uruchomić
też bym chciał się dosiąść
do klubu rockowego we Lwowie
znajduje się na ulicy Czerniowce i
Charków następnie chciałem odwiedzić plac i
filharmonia
jeśli kiedykolwiek miałeś gdzieś sen
było kilku tudulistów, trochę tuzit a
teraz to samo
żeby to odłożyć, teraz nie ma gdzie mieszkać
[muzyka]
o po
W 14 roku myślę o wiele więcej
właśnie w społeczeństwie coś takiego powstało
zainteresowanie tym, co jest w ogóle
Mariupol będąc na Ukrainie i co to jest
właściwie uczucie Mariupola na Ukrainie
[muzyka]
20 marca to dzisiejsze urodziny
lordyka to mój pies
Ten terier trochę schudł, ale
Sąsiedzi bardzo mu dziękowali
kawałek piersi z kurczaka jest pyszny
Zjadłem śniadanie i nadal je tu mam
odnotuj, że tata poszedł do babci mówisz
nad morzem Tu przyszedłem z innym
na zaproszenie sąsiadów są włączone
zaproszeni do ich domu, bo nie wiedzieli po co
jesteśmy w centrum, tam jest o wiele bardziej niebezpiecznie, bo
wszystko przelatuje przez ciebie, a oni mieszkają w pobliżu
morze i właśnie powiedzieli, że przyjdą
nas do nas o wiele ciszej nigdy sam
Nie czułem się tak w mieście
zarówno w nowoczesnym mieście, jak iw XXI wieku
który jest bardzo żywy, jest bardzo aktualny
tylko tak pulsujący nigdy sam
Nie czułem się tak, wiesz, to proste
Era kamienia łupanego
jak wtedy Cóż, jest to również doświadczenie wszystkich ludzi
ponieważ Cóż, to jest to samo, co na początku
no cóż, do pewnych rzeczy trzeba się przyzwyczaić
rzeczy, możesz automatycznie tam wejść
uruchom łazienkę, otwierając kran a
wtedy lub w ogóle, więc zamknij to
z powrotem i dobrze, jeśli tylko później To nie jest pierwszy
Minął tydzień i potem wszystko było ok
zrozumiałem to
diabeł zabiera mi śnieg, nie topnieje
mieszkanie lub w domu, co mam zrobić gdzie
Musiałem znaleźć wodę i wszystko było ze wszystkim
wszystko musiało zostać wydobyte, jeśli takie było
Myślę, że to było
Znajduję w tym pozytyw
ponieważ potrzebowałeś wszystkiego
jeśli tak, to powiedzieć, aby to zrobić
polowanie na zasób, ponieważ po pierwsze
jesteś bardzo podniecony przez coś takiego
towarzyskie i jeśli to twoja sprawa
zwierzęta są bardzo mocno uwzględnione
instynkt samozachowawczy i ty
Zaczynasz właśnie teraz. Cóż, właśnie teraz
szukać zasobu jakoś oryginalnie, bezpośrednio
bardzo z każdej strony
dlaczego nie byliśmy pod takim wrażeniem?
jakoś już przybyli No nie wiem
Nastąpiła taka natychmiastowa ulga
po prostu niewiarygodne. Och, po tym, jak jesteś z
który opuścił swój region
wyzdrowiał osobiście, stał się dla mnie obcy
nie chcę
pozwól sobie tak myśleć, ale
z powodu tego, czego naprawdę tam dla was doświadczyliśmy
po prostu cię wyrzucają, cały czas jesteś wyrzucany
staje się stałym takim rodzajem włóczęgi
na ojczystej ziemi i
gdyby tylko
widzieliśmy to już, kiedy wyjeżdżaliśmy
bo nie znam ludzi tam Zaporizhzhia nas
Spotkałem zobaczyłem Przy okazji znowu oczy
nadal namioty wolontariuszy
w którym można tam odpocząć
trzeba tam trochę pojeździć i się przekonać
wszelkie informacje lub informacje o wolontariuszach
mieszkanie
jest to dla mnie takie bezpośrednie
Byłem pod wrażeniem, że byłeś tylko ty, kiedy to był pierwszy raz
tym razem widziałem taką troskę o ludzi
tylko od innych ludzi i rozumiesz
Co do cholery, w końcu jestem w domu
w końcu dopiero teraz mam to w sobie
właśnie do swojej ojczyzny
kiedy widzisz troskę I kiedy widzisz
oto pokrewieństwo wszystkich ludzi, że wszyscy
pomagajcie sobie i tyle
czujesz się jak w domu
[muzyka]
Lwów jest dla mnie moim miastem, to proste
miasto gdzie
Mam wielu przyjaciół, mam wielu
wiele powiązań i dlatego jesteśmy tutaj jako rodzice
[muzyka]
jak czuję się bezpieczniej niż
bądź moim drugim rodzinnym miastem
[muzyka]
wiesz, oni po prostu tego chcą
zwycięstwo było dla wszystkich miast, a więc i dla mnie
Myślę, że kiedy
wszystkie miasta, które są teraz tymczasowe
lokalizacja lub zajęte, aby się stały
Ponownie
[muzyka]